now there is a new sort of selfie are
you aware of this thing not scaping no
but I can't wait do you know what not
scaping is okay so what you do is you're
your uten aboot and you see just a
wonder of nature a beautiful scenery a
landscape has true yeah and then you not
scape it you're not though yeah you
basically you drop your testicles into
so a picture a picture paints a thousand
words this is the website nuts Cape
that's it right there that's essentially
it
am I crazy agree that that's wonder now
you know there's two nuts they are
outside
a lot of them alone quite chilly look at
that every that's not enough that's what
it quick where that same look off to the
side there it's very old
Hey oh look at that at the one
no no don't it now this hello that not
check that's nice dear
there's something wrong look at the
shadow it's making where's my favorite
one look at the hair on that one just
cows
it was my favorite one my favorite one
is so beautiful it's a real incredibly
artistic check a lot ours
are you in a ways I'm glad that damp
turns over oh yeah no I really am
because she honestly she was about her
bent down like this and I think you
could hear the click you know you just
hear it you get used to that clicking
sound I thought oh yeah these pants are
really like they're oh I think my ass is
hanging out